So today, when you look at personal protective equipment for microbial risk such as coronavirus,...
...you're looking at four items.
And they would be a face shield, followed by a respirator of some sort...
...followed by a disposable coverall and finally gloves.
Coveralls, face shields, goggles and gloves protect against hazards like Ebola...
...that can spread by direct contact with bodily fluids.
The respirator prevents inhaling droplets in the air from sneezes and coughs.
Healthcare workers wear respirators while treating patients during the SARS and MERS outbreaks.
While both respirators and surgical masks are effective at filtering out large droplets,...
...surgical mask are less effective at filtering out smaller droplets...
...which can be inhaled through the sides of the masks.